on va parler de votre nouvelle
biographie chez Fayard Alexandra
Koh-Lanta c'est son nom la Valkyrie de
la Révolution une femme russe vous allez
le voir à la trajectoire exceptionnelle
un peu comme vous d'une certaine façon
votre portrait d'abord signé Marion
Becker et on parle de cette héroïne
juste après
madame le secretaire perpétuel vous êtes
la première femme à occuper ce fauteuil
de l'Académie française l'une des
gardiennes du temple de la langue
française en m'accueillant ambitieux
dans votre compagnie que votre illustre
fondateur voulu lieu de mémoire et de
défense de la culture française
vous avez répondu au rêve de l'enfant
que je fus
vous m'avez donné le droit de me sentir
pleinement membre en leur lieu le plus
prestigieux de la communauté spirituelle
et de la tradition de la France
troisième femme à entrer dans la
prestigieuse institution vous ne goûtez
guère à la féminisation des mots ou à
l'écriture inclusive ça ne sert à rien
d'aller ajouter un e à perpétuel d'abord
on ne s'adresse pas à moi en disant
est-ce Secrétaire perpétuel on dit
Madame le Secrétaire perpétuel essayons
de pas massacrer la langue mais faut pas
être intolérant l'Académie française
n'est pas un gendarme de la langue c'est
le greffier de l'usage
quel destin incroyable que le vôtre
fille d'immigrer Géorgiens apatride les
ourabich Billy qui n’apprenait le
français qu'à 4 ans et qui veillait
aujourd'hui sur la langue de Voltaire
votre enfant s'est studieux élève puis
enseignante à Sciences Po spécialiste de
l'histoire de la Russie et de l'Union
soviétique dès 1978 dans votre première
et celle empire éclatée vous annoncez la
fin de l'URSS 11 ans avant la chute du
mur de Berlin ce livre prophétique vous
apportera le succès et une notoriété
internationale vous consacrerez votre
vie à l'étude du pays de vos ancêtres et
à ses bouleversements politiques
vous avez eu l'air de croire que je me
faisais que
au cinéma je vais au théâtre je vais
voir les expositions et je lis et je ne
veux pas devenir idiote en faisant
qu'une seule chose moins connue votre
engagement européen vous amènera à
présider le comité pour le Wii au
référendum de Maastricht en 1994 dans la
foulée vous devenez député européenne
nommé vice-présidente de la Commission
des Affaires étrangères à Strasbourg et
pourtant vous l'assurez vous n'avez
jamais été engagé politiquement
alors on va revenir un petit peu sur
votre parcours avant de parler
d'Alexandra Koh-Lanta il y a berger
orgien une mer italienne d'origine
Germano ruche russe vous vous appelez
Hélène ma mère n'était italien que
nationalité parce qu'elle était née à
Florence ah d'accord rien à voir avec
l'Italie
allemande
et je dirais de culture plutôt russe
Hélène zura vos parents vous l'avez
raconté ont connu la pauvreté des
familles émigrées petit appartement 24
mètres carrés que vous ont-ils transmis
pour avoir au fond cette villa
aujourd'hui d'écriture d'enseignement
académicienne la politique ils vont
transmis une certitude c'est que on
faisait sa vie et que personne n'était
victime du destin
il suffisait ça c'était leur doctrine il
suffisait d'aimer les livres d'étudier
et la vie nous appartenait et je dois
dire je garde un très bon souvenir de
mon enfance même si elle était
compliquée matériellement mais
ça c'est pas tragique
et par contre quand on voit les gens
dans dormir dans la rue on sait très
bien que rien n'est tragique le Russe
avant le français pourquoi vous avez
vous êtes né en France mais vous avez
parlé
parce que mes parents ont considéré que
comme il ne pouvait pas avoir une nounou
qui me parle russe il n'est pas l'argent
pour ça pour être complètement bilingue
il valait mieux que je commence par
parler une langue dans un pays étranger
que j'acquierai complètement et puis que
la suivante le français viendrait
naturellement et que ça deviendrait ma
vraie langue ma vraie langue maternelle
c'était un calcul très juste en effet
jusqu'à 4 ans je parlais russe à 4 ans
et demi on m'a mis chez des amis aux
personnes ne parlent les Russes
trois mois plus tard je parlais
parfaitement de langue et à 4 ans et
demi j'ai commencé à prendre à lire en
français et ce nom de Chevilly est-ce
que vous l'aimez vous avez beaucoup
raconté votre immense honneur cette joie
au moment où vous êtes devenu français
beaucoup plus tard et je dois dire je
l'ai toujours dit quand j'étais en
classe et qu'on se levait en classe pour
dire comment vous appelez tout le monde
quand j'étais enfant il y avait pas
beaucoup
tellement d'étrangers en France où il y
en avait mais pas tellement mais par
conséquent tout le monde me regardait en
disant qu'est-ce que c'est que ce nom là
donc mon rêve c'était plutôt de
m'appeler Dupont ou durant voilà un nom
français un nom que vous avez donc
changé avec votre votre
mariage j'aurais pris un pseudonyme
français parce que je voulais être
compacte pour moi vous les entendez dans
la présidentielle sur l'assimilation sur
l'identité ce candidat examen pour ne
pas le nommer qui exige qu'on franchise
les prénoms
je crois qu'il faut que ça vienne c'est
soi-même mais si vous voulez il faut pas
forcer non mais ça tient à une chose
c'est que moi j'ai grandi dans un
univers avec des parents qui considérait
qu'on donnait moi j'ai été à patride
jusqu'à 21 ans parce que mes parents ont
dit de venir français cet animal il
faudra le demander il faut pas l'avoir
comme ça et je le considère jusqu'à
présent donc je considère que on choisit
soi-même son destin alors le destin
d'Alexandra elle l'a vraiment choisi ça
vous avez ça en commun d'une certaine
manière
quelle vitre épidante et pourtant si
méconnu première femme ministre nommée
par Lénine elle était commissaire aux
Affaires sociales première femme
ambassadeur nommée par Staline
racontez-nous qui était telle une
féministe une révolutionnaire d'abord
c'était une fille de l'aristocratie
russe c'est la première chose et là
histocratie russe au début du 20e siècle
c'était tout même classe privilégié et
en même temps
troublé par son statut de privilégier
beaucoup de je dirais de ni liste de
révolutionnaires se sont recrutés dans
cette classe
Lénine appartenait une excellente
famille aussi son père d'ailleurs Lénine
quand il s'est marié a mis noble
héréditaire sur son axe de mariage vous
voyez c'est un il était rare que
l'aristocratie aille vers la révolution
non mais justement si vous laissez Titus
être aristocrate ça n'impliquait pas du
tout qu'on jette un regard inquiet sur
la Révolution et tout naturellement elle
a été elle a été élevée dans des idées
libérales par ses parents elle a été
hantée par l'idée de savoir ce que
c'était que le socialisme etc est très
jeune elle a eu énormément et dès
qu'elle a pu elle a dit je vais aller
étudier
à la perfection et elle était pour le
pour dire jusqu'à quel point elle était
polyglotte elle était capable de faire
au moment où il a été aux États-Unis
elle l'a fait si meeting de la journée
ou c'est elle qui parlait en changeant
de public dans comparer un mythique
également un public allemand le suivant
amitigrus le troisième amitié français
etc elle passait de l'une à l'autre avec
une aisance formidable elle avait
d'abord cette ce dont des langues qui
lui a beaucoup servi parce que ça a
permis et à Lénine à Staline de
l'utiliser dans des missions
internationales
elle était une grande amoureuse aussi et
une grande féministe et c'est vraiment
ce qui est intéressant dans dans le
livre c'est ce combat qu'elle porte
auprès d'hommes les grandes figures de
la Révolution bolchevik alors sont tous
sauf des féministes c'est des gros
machistes tout à fait racontez-nous
comment elle arrive à se faire sa place
dans ce monde là elle disait par exemple
la Lénine on fait l'amour comme on avale
un verre d'eau elle choquait elle l'a
beaucoup choqué Lénine qui n'aimait pas
beaucoup ses idées je dirais féministes
Lénine était très très conventionnelle
il faut bien le savoir même si elle-même
a été choquée après quand êtes rendu
compte que Lénine sa femme et Inessa
Armand qui était un petit peu sa rival
je dirais dans le parti il est serment
était une femme de son genre enfin qui
était aussi polyglotte qui était
remarquablement intelligente simplement
elle est morte très tôt puisqu'elle a
été elle a attrapé le tissu ça a été le
désespoir de Lénine elle en voyant le
trio Lénine Issa Armand skaya était
aussi un peu choqué vous voyez c'est
même cette femme tout à fait libérale
alors cela dit elle était c'est
intéressée au sort des femmes très tôt
mais féministe elle avait une vision du
féminisme qui n'est pas celle que nous
comprenons c'est à dire pour elle le
féminisme c'est pas de vouloir la même
chose que les hommes
c'est tout simplement d'être soi-même
c'était pas égalitariste ça lui
intéressait pas parce que l'égalité
c'est comme elle disait c'est par
rapport à quelqu'un déjà en se dévalue
des féministes ou des néoféministes
d'aujourd'hui au fond sont un peu dans
la guerre des sexes en tout cas la
déconstructions c'était une grande
amoureuse elle a eu des hommes dans sa
vie elle a eu des grandes passions
elle a aussi été une mère et une
grand-mère passionnée c'est-à-dire elle
a été une femme complète mais son idée
c'était que la révolution c'est cela la
révolution pouvait changer le destin des
femmes la révolution est un projet
social où les femmes étaient des êtres
humains c'est-à-dire pas des femmes par
rapport à l'homme c'était pas où toi de
là que je m'y mette c'est je prends la
place qui me revient quand vous
expliquez quel était oubliée de
l'histoire Staline y a contribué
l'histoire soviétique a effacer tout le
monde à partir de elle vous l'avez dit
non pas la première femme ministre la
seconde la première famille ministre a
été nommée au par les le gouvernement
constitutionnait démocrate c'est-à-dire
la révolution de Février et Alexandra
Koh-Lanta a été nommé par Lénine au même
poste qui avait occupé la première femme
ministre du gouvernement de février
a échappé au purge elle qui au fond
a été maligne et habile il n'en reste
rien aujourd'hui en tout cas dans
l'histoire commune si en Russie sont
la preuve c'est que mon livre est
achevé la traduction s'achève et les
gens l'attendent parce que ils ont envie
de savoir j'ai pu aller dans les
archives comme j'ai travaillé vraiment
sur toute sa vie
ils veulent savoir et on l'attend en
France aussi c'est à lire aux éditions
fayardes la Valkyrie de la Révolution
Alexandra Koh-Lanta on sent aussi cette
plume passionnée que vous avez raconté
son histoire vous restez je voulais
rajouter bien sûr elle avait un immense
mérite parce que si elle est surveillée
on me dit toujours pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle Staline ne l'a pas tué comme
tous les autres je dirais qu'elle est
survécu par son intelligence sa manière
de je dirais de se rendre utile mais
elle n'a jamais fait ce qu'on fait la
plupart des bolcheviks elle n'a jamais
dénoncé personne et ça c'est aussi ça
montre qu'une femme est capable de faire
ce que personne n'est capable de faire